john roos et wisi au renouveau de cette
crise il se trouve pour le dernier
épisode
angie dans le to put 1 le dernier
comment ça va se terminer wébo papilouve
précédemment dream team
mike ya pas de calais pour le
téléphérique josh il doit la voir
il est parti c'est trop tard elle a
probablement emmenées dans la mine ne
bouge plus
pères
obama
je vais chercher cette clé direct dans
la somme de cette bestiole et après je
me sors tous de cet enfer faut qu'on
trouve un moyen d'aller là où il s'est
emparé
mon
chapitre 10 résolutions une heure
jusqu'à l'os et le pis c'est peter beck
sa part en quoi la c'est josh en face
kermode pas bien je me demande si ces
sessions vous semble qu'une quelconque
utilité
vous n'écoutez pas et la situation est
[Musique]
compliquée je dois vous l'idée
maintenant jo genou est grand temps pour
vous de comprendre qu'il existe de plus
grand danger en dehors de l'imagination
orbite est déséquilibré d'un camion
plaisant et messieurs dans ce genre vous
aimez et tenait à vous étaient prêts à
vous aider mais vous les avez tous
repoussés succès ses deux seuls sous la
voiture bélier vraiment voilà sol
mais vu la tournure des choses ça ne
devrait pas durer [ __ ] vous ne serez
pas seul longtemps en fait ça c'est ce
qui se passe dans sa tête
le psy avec le bureau et l'isf et celle
interne de sa tête quoi c'est pour ça
que là on le voit carrément dans
l'endroit où il est vraiment avec le psy
à côté qui lui parle alors que tu début
envoyé dans son bureau
prenez encore ces médicaments
[Musique]
à
un iceberg qui chante sait pas trop quel
[Rires]
os [ __ ] je pioche du coup ya super
sauver mon gars oh la la c'est génial a
laissé par tourner en garde on n'était
pas là
oh mon dieu boukila il va se faire entre
fiction mettez la main
what u ne va pas sauver yachir pourquoi
tu voulais qu'on meurt
[Musique]
ah le pauvre c'est quoi ça c'est le
psychopathe que du navire
oui
le port le confort signer
c'est quoi ce délire à ses phobies et
ses phobies c'est ce qu'on aime chez le
psy du coup on avait peur voilà du sang
oh [ __ ]
terra temps qu'elle
pourquoi tu voulais combat il est hanté
du cuss un truc de malade
elle
yp est complètement un câble alors nous
sommes donc dans les mines avec ça mais
mike mois tonga mais je suis content
c'est le plus gros bonhomme que la terre
inconnue c'est génial on va dans l'eau
et s'ils savent nager le wedding au cd
wendy o d'offres sur suis encore vivant
arrête ça vient de rentrer dans l'eau
calme toi je sais pas pourquoi gros lot
en fait à pour passer pour faut prendre
ce passage là ok [ __ ] si on tombe sur
josh ce serait génial et we go qui on
arrive à la rive d'en face on remonte
une porte mon gars on y va c'est parti
aux toutes les têtes des cadavres que
les walis son couplet
dhaouadi guapo féminin je ne sais pas
anna wen mais ne te jure times non mais
je t'assure regardez pas vous avez rien
vu est en train de péter un câble c'est
parce qu'il a arrêté ses ces médicaments
qui est comme ça ici tyrosse et vieux
papiers d'été parti loin un mec c'était
complètement dingue à penser pas traîné
ok allez on se casse ici à l'ego à l'ego
aligot du téléphérique attends tu vois
ça là bas ça veut dire qu'il ya une
sortie directe
oui ok si vous m'aidez je peux rentrer
pour dire aux autres qu'on a bien eu des
scans en fait ça me paraît pas si on se
retrouve au chai hockey comme ça on sait
pas on sort tous ok ait voici à l'esam
bonne chance donc ces trois voire deux
choses qui se retrouve avec mike alors
que vaille qu'il a explosé de vue de
patates et voilà je suis pas bien je
sais je sais par là à faire ça dans sa
tête encore g20 - du beau mec dans l'eau
non s'il te plaît non non décent bonjour
aller dans l'eau de la mort où un oui du
goût va nous couper les jambes
joshi va mourir c'est josh qui va
décéder je suis prêt à faire acquitter
un je vous le dis
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez vu non non
pas mal non il est réellement derrière
les rêves oceanor ses buts et son frère
des wanna fuck yeah ce matin dit aux
mecs mais à nay fille qu elle fit quatre
mois et au plus tard au tout juste un
siphon de 6,7 fin de série là je kiffe
jeu c'est génial yapi cordoba qui nous
ferait du bien c'est super bon choix
seul dans les mines
le voici se cacher c'est de courir se
cacher tu fais pas de bruit ne fait pas
de bruit ne fait pas de bruit
c'est pour ça qu'on était bien non la
soupe est en vie ça se fait dans be nice
wendy go voyages sont des sorties au
moncade j'ai cette envie j'ai six heures
retourne sur ça s'arrête pas de changer
de personnage on voit qu'il ya plein
d'action quoi c'est chaud a laissé un
méchoui du hockey escalade escalade
escalade
ok on est enfin c'est génial alain
bouillard droite ou gauche gauche gauche
bombe à l'estec la taz aimerait
tellement voir des flammes la banque
envoyé le mec avec nous en sommes on
avait peur maintenant on rêve de voir ça
on a envie [ __ ] qui est des flammes
partout je vous ai dit qu crève
c'est sale con auquel on retombe sur la
cabane [ __ ] vielles calme et ça c'est
là où on avait enfermé de georges vrai
et c'est là où crise c'est fatah cake
mais comment c'est un [ __ ] c'est un
peu le qg les manigances je veux ça faut
pas que je rate mon gars c'est chaud
quoique jeu rapide un chômage y aller ok
on y est c'est fermé non ils sont pas
rétablies tard ils sont plus là c'est
celle ci il se retourna au chalet h est
fait dans l'achat sam
offerts
[ __ ] mais lui s'est fait toucher par à
moins de 10 go il va être contaminés
bien pire si on traîne non c'est bon
c'est une bonne idée ça casse tête pour
rentrer comme ça le web où ils pourront
faire pareil alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
je sais pas alors voilà au sol
jamais jamais jamais faire l'important
l'attend en est encore là bas - eric
ciotti député c'est bien ça bordel c'est
bien çà mau
ils sont dans la maison bordel auch est
tellement bien fait fermer la porte à
mon dieu parce que j'ai bien fait alors
je suis là vous non non
bush
[Musique]
ça je te la mets tellement mon gars tu
as fait chaud
sont partout ils sont partout dans la
maison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
watt en sata contrôle
la tour
il ay la paire ceinture de 4 mon gars on
se casse faut qu'on se casse
cette idée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais tout le monde a brûlé dans dehors
du fait qu'on va mieux début du jeu il
semble qu'un morceau
parce que ça
ce coup rappelé pâte pour pour manger en
fait tâche bravache est ok ok ok
[Musique]
c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est sonia
généraux
[Musique]
sauvé maïs je veux sauver maïs ou pas
mais je veux petit tour
voilà c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
je suis tétanisé
[Musique]
oh lala média jeu williams il faut je me
cache son combat l'interrupteur toi je
sais pas je sais pas je me cache mon cas
je me cache vous risquez trouvé ce que
je me cache
j'attends encore un peu
c'était lyon c'était long [ __ ] alias
pat et vous tous les deux battez-vous
tous les deux comme ça on fait diversion
cou et de se cacher encore je sais pas
il ya un mot et flare courir mec je sais
pas quand c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt
ce cache encore tout d'abord la veille
j'attends que vraiment les deux se jette
d'un sur le ton de gâcher pour me
couvrir
[Musique]
anais la sauver
on a plus qu il fallait [ __ ] ils sont
pleins être en vie oh [ __ ] c'est
l'aube en plus c'est la fin c'est la fin
du jeu oh [ __ ] j'ai jamais été aussi
tendu ma vie
allez enora lamda netbook soit quelques
chansons à tous oui parce qu'on a bien
fait les cultes et 8 août à l'époque des
faits c'est la fin et les vosges a
ajouté un trophée way en [ __ ] c'est
fini c'est fini
et bam à la gente ailée afin de se les
peler [ __ ] c'était incroyable intense
et [ __ ] on n'aurait jamais dit que
c'était une espèce de gulu en fait les
le danger on aurait vraiment dit
qu'avant psychopathe qui rôdaient autour
du truc mais ça tu dois ressembler ce
que vous avez été hyper nombreux à
suivre à me demander à tout le temps en
temps des épisodes sur les sort les
super cool et ben voila merci à tous
d'avoir suivi on revoit l'explosion tête
du pauvre du groupe enjoy
je suis tout ému c'est fini à plein tube
down c'est fou et je vous dis à bientôt
portez vous bien que autour de baisse
merci
on va voir
à
perpère belle facture
déjà
il aura
occupant
[Musique]